like I saw the five the phantom pain is
all anyone in this goddamn office has
been talking about after the past weeks
all your fault Peter brand a 10g much
more Brown my fault is it good gym is
full to this could use it's a pretty
great game Mike my heart are you
enjoying it yeah I'm really liking it
this whole weekend that's all I did I'm
talking about it as difficult because
there weren't a spoiler territory I need
anybody in this office to finish the
game there's like I'm not letting things
that come out of people's mouths I'm
like yeah but oh yes here he's
constantly grunting and sighing from
were like his desk someone said
something like so that's gonna happen
I'm like five percent and after like 20
hours or something so don't worry we're
not gonna get into spoilers here on
today's job but we are gonna talk about
something like the interesting things
that have happened to us during random
missions the interesting moments that
make like a metal gear game not talking
about stuff that we unlock or things
that happen but like just interesting
things that have happened i guess the
wonderful fruits of emergent gameplay
which happen in this game speaking of
emerging fruits i did find a cassette
tape with the sound of a soldier pooping
i found out too yeah I wish you could
set it as the sound on your helicopter
do you like that Segway yeah that's
pretty good at the pc version I've seen
people you can basically just put in
like any old mp3 into that folder and
just like make the helicopter oh yeah
cuz that was like the wrestling yes
right yeah dirty Dan Reicher did that
himself and you could do that with the
Phuket cuz that as well every time the
helicopter comes cuz I said it like an
hour or two into the game and now every
time helicopter comes be to pick me up
or like support it's like playing take
on me by haha like I'm it really takes
the edge off I can really tense
situation was like did it no dude yeah
you're coming in the distance like a I
guess or the creepy creepy helicopter
what type of moments have you had that
sort of stand out to you goober uh this
was something I found early on that I
thought was like maybe a glitch or
something but then we've determined that
this is a real mechanic in a game is
sledding in the cardboard box yeah so
when you're in the box you're crouched
but you can stand up and run into a
sprint and if you hit square if you're
on PlayStation to dive if you fall on a
decline you will actually slide down and
so like you can find some males that are
really tall and go for like 30 seconds
like straight and it's
it's really fun like it stupid and
simple but I don't know it's one you can
use it to escape uh-uh presumably have
not done so okay but I feel like a part
of this game is gonna be like hunting
down the sickest slopes yeah like really
just [ __ ] guest a tuna gamespot.com
yeah it's coming soon and Mike what's at
the moment you were talking today about
a mission that I played last night which
yeah pretty cool yeah there's a mission
later on where you just have to pretty
much I don't think it's a spoiled little
up vehicles you just have to blow up
vehicles and they're on like planned
routes that you have to or route if
you're one of those people thank you
yeah that you have to kind of just like
do a certain amount of them in a certain
amount of time and I had c4 planted on
the road in one spot like two of them
and then I had another one that I kind
of just forgot about because I pressed
the wrong button to set it okay and I
went prone waiting because I knew they
were gonna be along the path and all of
a sudden Asajj is waiting and I threw on
rebel yell by billy idol because that's
one of my favorite songs the game to
play and then they came along and I
press triangle nothing happened but i
was getting i got points for something
oh wow during what i got it for cuz the
trucks in front of me were fine press
triangle few more times a blow-up and I
realized the 1i just like the throw away
when I had accidentally put on the
ground before head blown up like some
other vehicle Wow yeah I never went back
to check but it just kind of cool that
that came out of that situation because
it wasn't expecting that obviously it
wasn't planned I mean I'll tell people
to nature was planned but I was running
around on d horse with a rocket launcher
which I trust and I guess researched and
I hadn't actually used it before so like
the same mission where it's like you'd
shut the boy it blow up a bunch of
vehicles and I like okay well I do I
find like the highest point in the
topography and like stay up there and
like crouch and like get in a good place
for this anti-tank weapon and like just
get it down the sights and in shooting I
did that a couple of times and then I
realized it's like so many of these
vehicles to blow up that I'm never all
going to come to me on time yeah so I
hop on the horse and I'm like looking
for a place to like use the rocket
launcher and I'm like what if I can use
the rocket launcher while on this horse
it could never be the case in the real
world but Hideo Kojima doesn't give a
[ __ ] so I was like running around on the
horse d horse would like this rocket on
my [ __ ] shoulder it's just like
taking shots and I was amazing and then
wanted them turn
and saw me I like just blew the crap at
adi horse and i will flew across the the
the dirt in behind a rock speaking of
our dear i blowing the crap out of d
horse i got the command that you can
just have him defecate it's yeah i don't
i haven't used it yet but that's like
the last thing I in live before stopping
to pie last night to fecal topics I just
want yeah yeah engage in more thing yeah
oh okay emergent gameplay from marrakech
if you play the recording of the poop in
the bath no wait a min why can't sink
why can't there just be a command for
him to imitate pooping why don't you get
the consent of nine out of ten I keeper
something wasn't willing to record that
piece oh yeah okay that's pretty great
uh isn't a thing with the earlier games
they're all these little things like
that to find like you know like that the
stuff in the locker and metal gear solid
releasing the models posters yeah cuz
like now they've got another solid five
so huge is kind of like baffling to how
many little things i'm sure people start
finding you did somebody with a Supply
Drop yes no I just found out today you
could do that yeah kill myself they were
to supply he doesn't really kill you
just kind of no but I've randy was
telling you can do it too quiet oh
really yeah no spoilers let's keep at it
oh yeah yeah that's what I heard today
as well do it can do 2d horse probably
as well speaking of the horse and supply
drops are all good segways all over the
place um I the first time I decided to
try sliding in the box I had previously
called in d horse like a buddy supplied
her up whatever it's called to the top
the slope I just beaten like a boss so I
was kind of tell abrading head you know
take on me playing and I went to slide
down the hill and all sudden d horse
drops in front of me and I hidden he did
that Winnie and he went like flying
under side it was worried I had done
more damage but he got back up Oh once I
dropped into a level and was like riding
them the road on d horse and which but
it's never not going to be weird saying
d horse it's just just [ __ ] leave
name forth and and there's a truck
coming towards me it was like really
early and I didn't I was like freaked
out I was like [ __ ] I jumped off the
earth and run I've totally forgot about
this and I ran behind like a boulder and
just like dough bind it as the
chocolates commander corner yeah and I
hear going
she's [ __ ] male d horse and I turned
the corner and the guys are like getting
out of the car Larry yeah the horse is
on the ground and yeah just [ __ ]
perfect album that it was a perfect
opportunity to kill it's actually really
good tactic to use during one of those
like missions we have to blow up tanks
and stuff oh really you've used that oh
yeah yeah cuz they're good they're not
gonna they're gonna run of course or
they're gonna get out and say whoa yeah
get out of the way any other moments
come to mind you a mission without using
reflex before I'd yeah IM done IM i
still didn't get the aspen i was just i
think i just took a really long time um
but yeah I was it was one of those ones
really it was a side task was to extract
a prisoner and had him on my back and I
always get really tense someone's on my
back was you know we have less options
especially when you can all use a
sidearm you know just yeah and I was
walking through the village with him on
my back some one of these people and
there's like three guys are there I mean
I knew because they were previously
marked so I saw them kind of searching
they had something and alerted them i
think only open the door too loudly and
i just made it through without alerting
anyone extracted him with a full and
rode away and the horse playing some
sort of song got picked up and went out
without people knowing i was there is
like that could have easily gone wrong
so many ways but yeah just got lucky and
I I guess patience paid off it's great
when you get like that like sand storm
comes in at just the best time oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah when you're like scouting out
a mission like how am I gonna do this oh
the constant approaching I had one where
I have to go in and collect this like
this like really battered prisoner like
an extract him and I had I found this
other prisoner first who I was like
carrying him out and then I went down
into like there was like a grill
underneath the base you could like crawl
under left not a good solid one saw but
I dropped him in and then there was like
no way of getting there cuz you can't
climb out with the body yeah and you
can't push him down yeah keep his body
damn it then the grill uh so I was like
I got a [ __ ] Fulton him but like no
one else knew I was in the base yeah so
I like just Fulton the guy I was I
realized oh my god I can fold to him and
then popped him up and then literally it
was just like look like everyone just
yeah zoned in on me so I run in I'm like
okay I better get the other guy and I
ran in got the real prisoner carried a
mouse and there was like three guys like
reflex mode like coming up the stairs
I'm
I just had my like gone I'm like oh
throw this prisoner I'm like he's
probably gonna die but he was all right
did you find the little Hedgehog that
was crawling around those little vents
no oh yeah yeah I've seen a rat I've
seen the Hedgehog as well duh and like
you there you couldn't Fulton them
obviously but when I saw the Hedgehog
later in the wild I was like sweet but
you can't do it you actually you can
capture them usually get these little
animal traps climb Eve so you leave it
out and then just randomly like over
time it'll be like oh no you got an
animal to support team brought it back
to base for you I just got I've had it
but haven't used it so I've laid some
traps today yeah really want some
hedgehogs for what reason got to go fast
okay blue head shot good shot no i don't
sorry i was done but now I was dumb no
because you have a zoo where are these
hedgehogs gonna go in the zoo good mean
mug in the camera they're just kind of
like that mean mugging they're just
gotta like crawl underneath the barriers
and then just like yeah probably just
like lemmings yeah these moments keep
happening it's what I love about it it's
like you can't talk about the story
stuff cuz your spoiler but we keep
coming into the office and having these
like crazy like little asides about it
and you've obviously paid more of the
games than anyone does this continued do
you think that you keep like finding new
ways to enjoy the game like thread
hundred hours plus of málaga solid oh
yeah like uh like what one point you
unlock the water pistol and like a it's
just a little squirt gun and I hadn't
really thought about much about I
thought it was kind of a gimmick but I
only recently found out that you can use
that to like blind soldiers so if they
catch you and they're like oh no and it
cancels the reflex and the alert you and
you can use it to take out electronics
as well oh wow so it totally does all of
these layers keep appearing that I never
knew existed before so yeah I mean
there's and again I'm only forty-six
percent now after maybe another eight
hours like there's still so much to tap
into yeah yeah so many weird stuff to
find and discover mike my hardy Peter
Brown thanks for coming on talk about
Metal Gear Solid thank you Bob thank you
boss Thank You boss okay it's great not
your mother loved that video game and
let us know you think about make
yourself I've at the phantom pain
interesting emergent gameplay moments
that you had yourself in the comment box